Frederick and Carlos Hoffman run a
family business in Barcelona it was
founded by their German father in 1972
the sons were born in Catalonia and
follow developments they're closely
[Music]
there's a lot of tension in the air
wherever you go everybody is talking
about just one thing independence those
in favor and those who are against it
society is deeply divided their fault
that three years ago their late father
and other German business people in
Barcelona issued an appeal for the
Catalan leadership to abandon its quest
for independence and to negotiate with
the Spanish government to no avail of
course the hoffmans company mundo calor
manufactures lighting with customers all
over the world it sells a lot to the
Gulf states we export three-quarters of
our output so it's very important for
our company that Catalonia remains in
the eurozone that's Catalunya espana in
the auditory blood this company siddik
manufactures speciality chemicals it's
boss Josep Maria Miguel is in favor of
independence for Catalonia during the
financial crisis that erupted in 2008
the company boosted its exports to
reduce its dependence on the domestic
market I mean Gail says independence
need not harm the economy we want the
best possible administration and the
most democratic form of government we've
evaluated the risks and we believe the
issue is a political one and
independence shouldn't affect our
business unless that is the Spanish
government decides to adopt methods that
are not particularly democratic Spain
has issued a decree making it easier for
companies to move their headquarters
from one region to another Catalonia's
two biggest banks have said they're
moving their legal headquarters
elsewhere
more than 500 firms have already made a
similar move the Catalonian government
doesn't think the decree will have a
major impact their manufacturing plants
will remain in Catalonia then they'll
stay here because Catalonia is where
they will find the best conditions for
their businesses economist Montserrat
called the thorns sees it differently
for years she's been warning of the
risks of secession she says companies
moving their legal headquarters is much
more than just a symbolic gesture the
companies will not build new factories
install new machines develop new
businesses or make fresh investments all
the things that guarantee economic
development because firms will no longer
have legal security here or access to
European networks or sources of capital
copied Aled Johanna Romero of Catalonia
trade and investment concedes that
insecurity can dampen the propensity to
invest some companies will stick to
their investment plans others will
choose to wait and see for a while which
doesn't mean that they won't invest
independent amending Frederick Hoffman
bought another production hall two years
ago he needed to boost capacity after
receiving a big order today he wouldn't
go ahead with a purchase we would not
expand at the moment we would wait for
the situation to become more stable it's
a problem the independence movement is
roiling markets other small and
medium-sized companies like ours will
probably put their plans on hold for the
time the standoff between the
pro-independence Catalan government and
the Spanish government is set to
continue and there's no easy resolution
in sight